first of all thank you for wearing this
shirt tonight why was it important to
you
oh gosh because i i think those young
fellas are amazing yeah
yeah that's all okay great that's it i'm
not the only one but you know
but you know yeah that's it well look
you just gave me a ted lasso answer
right off the bat and the question for
you is
are you ted last so do people come up to
you now and say hi ted lasso are they
still saying hi jason
they do say hi jason i mean i'll hear
could lasso every now and then but yeah
but but i've been lucky enough to do a
lot of different things so i was just
texting with my my buddies rob mcclaney
and charlie day saying
that i do get called schmidty which i
played on it's always sunday in
philadelphia so
i've had enough guest starring roles on
other people's
you know yeah great shows that uh i i
get called a lot of names well look this
is major starring and and this is your
show and you guys just set the record
the most
emmy nominations for a freshman comedy
series ever it's so incredible
congratulations
who was your first call when you got the
news oh gosh
i don't think i called anyone who calls
anyone these days it's all text right
okay i just got told by marcus mumford
that you leave the world's longest voice
text so who did you leave a voice text
to oh
boy that's that's i mean i'm still
leaving one as we speak i do really
leave long
voice notes i have a tendency to ramble
you're still writing it in your head
yeah yeah um did you tell your kids do
your kid their kids know dad just
won all these nominations and is it no
no they don't care they don't care
no they want to know if they they want
to know if they can play their nintendo
switch
if they can get an another stuffy they
don't they they they know
have they seen ted lasso and if they
have what do they think of the stash in
the southern drawl
they have seen ted lasso they refer to
otis refers to roy kent as the king of
the f
word king of the f i think is what he
says he doesn't say the word
no no i mean he no okay
he used to we got we we got him off that
we got
that but uh but yeah they've watched it
more otis than daisy
uh for i mean because
a four and a half year old you know but
a seven-year-old yeah he's good to go
yeah
he's r-rated yeah he gets it um by the
way ted lasso gets into a little girl
talk right off the bat this season
being a girl dad are you how are your
skills are you gonna vibe with daisy on
that one day do the girl talk
i think so i was lucky enough to uh you
know have a mom growing up
and uh two younger sisters so yeah i was
i had i had a i had a good um
you know a good entree into girl talk in
my in my in my kitchen you know with my
sisters and all their friends
you know as the older brother that lived
in the basement okay well
that's the place to be look where you
are now yeah just barely out of the
basement
well look this show truly has helped so
many people i mean myself include it was
the joy and the
emotional intelligence that i think we
all needed in this time
how has playing ted lasso helped you um
it gave me something to focus on
throughout the pandemic
you know like i i think so many of us
were
were left you know looking
for for something besides may you know
maybe maybe maybe some of the
the noise that we have a tendency to
listen to far too often but for me it
just gave me
you know something to just concentrate
on day by day to let help the days go by
uh and then also you know connecting
with
you know our editors in the in post
production but then also in our writers
room for season two
it was almost therapeutic you know to
check in with you know all those that
brady bunch of faces that we all had on
zoom or face time or whatever whatever
your you know your job happened to be
um you know that so that was fortunate
well speaking of you you guys focus on
mental health this season you've got a
therapist
why was it important to bring that
storyline into the show
i mean because that's what the story
that's where the story was headed anyway
okay
yeah i mean that's yeah i mean you know
sometimes you know
we all have stories within us so you
know
sometimes you got to go inside to see
what's going on and and there's
you know that that's just where it was
always headed okay well i have to ask
i'm still a couple i'm only a couple
episodes in how many of the other care
like are we gonna see all the characters
from season one i wanna see
the ex-husband again i want to see uh
your girl keely hazel's character again
is she coming back and what's it been
like working with her this season
uh it's been great yeah yeah we have
anthony head playing rupert and then she
plays bex
and yeah i believe they i believe that
anybody that anybody that shows up in
season one
they're in the universe and much like in
life you know you know you have a
tendency to bump into people that you
didn't think you were going to see again
and then
lo and behold they show up on your
doorstep sometimes so yeah yeah i think
i think we'll see all those folks again
and that's a good thing yeah i think i
mean it depends how you respond to them
and how they respond to you but yeah
there's an opportunity for harmony and
all those uh you know
reconnections well how are you are you
happy are you good you see like this is
a big night there are literally stadiums
set up for this show's per season from
here i know i just hope everybody um
yeah it's something else i mean i know i
feel good it's it's lovely weather and
it's great to see
people in person that i haven't seen in
a while that i've only connected through
zoom in on post-production so
that's great and seeing old friends so
yeah no i've got no complaints all right
real quick for season two what are the
fans gonna get tease it for him
oh boy i mean uh the uh some
the the idea is that sometimes the best
way to help others is to help yourself
oh wait hold on we gotta see that that
says daddy
what did she make that for she just made
it because she
can't not be creative she's a little
artist-to-be
future actress i don't know okay i feel
like she's currently acting a lot
uh sorry days but it's the truth
sometimes
oh she's so uh oh okay an oscar winner
okay
i mean from the 40s yeah i don't know if
it would play now
seems a little a little overwrought but
i have some notes but
no it's all right she's lovely